Ah, how does that work? How does that work? So, yeah, that that
is a problem for Destiny. Using a public forum to falsely class
Destiny as a predator. Destiny, your actions have kind of put
you in that light. I mean, the
It looks like chicken and stucco. Uh no matter what happens,
Andrew Brettler is the biggest winner in this case. Of course
he is.
Apparently, potentially criminal dropped a video a stream tonight.
Oh, Sean did a whole stream on Destiny versus Pixie update April
2026. Now, I think there's like something coming up in the trial
where there's going to be I think there's going to be Sorry,
I stopped at a weird frame. You're right. Uh I think
I think they're having like some sort of hearing, but I don't
know what the hearing even is. I saw something like a tweet from
Destiny like just like shut up Pixie again. He just He loves
talking [__] about Pixie. Do you think Destiny knows
that when he posts stuff to his community it goes to his main
page? I
I sometimes wonder if Destiny even knows that that stuff goes
out publicly. That like all the people who would associate with
him politically see that? Or maybe they just don't care. Like
you'd think you'd think like Hutch or Wick or some of these people
who said like they like Pixie, who are friends with Pixie, do
you think they'd like care in some way?
But apparently they just don't, which I I just like a little
baffling to me. That's all. It's a hearing on Pixie's motion
for a continuance. I thought So, again, I did not read all the
docs here, but I did read that basically Destiny hasn't even
sat for a deposition yet. And they're like, "Hey, we need a deposition
here. Like we we're not going to trial without a deposition."
It feels like insane. And there's just been this back and forth
where neither side wants to do the depositions.
And I don't know who's in the right and who's in the wrong there
cuz they just stopped ruling on stuff. Yeah, so it's like, "Well,
it totally makes sense to delay the trial, right?" But basically,
they're two kids refusing to talk to each other. And the the
adult has to come in and go, "You have to go first and then you
have to go." Right? And they they just can't talk side respects
each other enough to talk to each other anymore. But the adult
is just not ruling on anything. That's my impression of what's
going on here is both sides Yeah, yeah, I think I've seen those
There's like a motion you can do after your motion's been impending
for 90 days that's like, "Hey, what the hell?" There's like a
There's like a ping on the court. "Hey, what the And I've seen
like multiple of those. So, if you guys have not seen the court
case here, um this court case is
it's a case of Doe versus Benell. Um even though Pixie we know
who Pixie is, she's suing under Jane Doe um and she's suing Destiny,
whose name is Steven Benell. And this is down in the Southern
District of Florida, and we started all the way back. He just
says that her lawyers are not making the best case they could
have. Yeah, that seems reasonable. In February of last year,
and since then
we're now up to filing 235.
So, unlike the Russell Greer case, this is actually a good example
of like a
there's still a lot of motion practice here, but it's not as
bad as you know, Russell Greer acting like a So, it's still a
ton. It's still a ton though. It's still a ton though. Destiny
made for good legal representation. I think like I agree on that.
I've seen a lot of the I've seen like the motions from before.
It seemed like they do a good job of arguing stuff, and it can
be difficult to see Basically, somehow I feel like Destiny's
legal representation is just totally fine with lying. Like they'll
just totally lie about different situations.
And I don't know that that sounds pretty funny to me that like
they they seem good. They'll just like lie and leave things out.
Is very interesting to me a lot of the time. Okay, we'll keep
we'll keep >> Now, where do we want to start? Well, we
ended we stopped in roughly October
on everything. And as we were in October, yeah, a couple things
happened.
I just This is more of what I want is his summation of things
since October. So, so the Rose solo siege. I mean, you should
be. You just you should be. What Hold on. Actually, didn't Oh
my god.
I could have sworn there was a clip that basically Destiny literally
says he he that obviously Rose was aware of him and talked to
him, and that she was just a go-between, right? Like there's
a clip of him saying that, which to me
that's quite literally what Pixie argues. So, isn't that like
a problem for his court case? But the biggest thing that happened
really, I think, in the meantime was
that there was an opportunity
to go forward, and Pixie's team sought out a deposition for uh
Melina, Destiny's ex-wife. Uh she lives in Sweden now. And it
you depose you want to serve discovery
throughout the world. The US is part of treaties and conventions
that allow for it. And it takes time. Now, the thing is this
didn't occur till late in the fall, and they've known that Destiny
had an ex-wife. They've known about her forever. The idea they
didn't know about her um I was This is one of those times where
I've been disappointed in Pixie's team. They did it really late.
Why did they do it so late? I don't know. But that's out there
That is still not been addressed at this point.
Um doing international things like this takes forever
in law. Post it in the group chat you have with uh Perry, Pixie's
lawyer Hassan Chud Queenman de la Guna, and Kyle Kulinski, and
Krystal Ball, and Pisco, and Well, we had Soy Pill in there for
a little bit, but we had to kick him out,
Um Kilo s- substance. Yeah, there's a lot of people in this group
chat. It's a big group chat, okay? Lawsuits and civil procedure.
It takes forever. And then ultimately ultimately
the real important thing here is on December 11th
Destiny went ahead and kind of just did the first major shot
across the bow of where they're at in this case and what they
think they're going to do. >> for sanctions. >> for
sanctions.
Oh. Destiny filed for sanctions. Now, what are they doing here?
Well, they're filing under rule 11. So, what do they point out
here? Um And this is where this is where we're going to read
through some of Destiny's comments and I'm like, "No, I think
we I think there's a valid case here despite what Destiny protest."
They claim the attempt to obfuscate the record, the rule 11 sanctions
are straightforward and are warranted as a matter of law.
In a pleading publicly filed on October 3rd, the plaintiff falsely
accused Destiny of transmitting
explicit material to a minor.
Since at least October 23rd, plaintiff and attorneys have known
the allegation was categorically false. Despite having the ample
opportunity to withdraw the false allegation and file a corrected
Was it false or was it incorrect?
Because remember like we start out with Destiny
has had
conversations with
And remember, we'll go back to this right here.
You know, it's actually insane Think about she could Dude, this
is the craziest thing. Her boyfriend was recording these calls
on Skype. That's just absolutely insane to think she was doing
uh Think about him doing all this if she was 17.
Like I I'm sorry, this is so obviously him talking about retaining
C Savage. It's just very funny. Remember, this is solo and Rose
Destiny's talking about. Then you have all this stuff here, you
know, that he talked with Rose and then he talked with Rose.
There was a lot of reason to believe Rose was a minor. Uh-oh.
So, the idea that it was false, well, it turned out to be false
later,
but you don't have to go back and amend those things you learn
that aren't correct later. If it was materially false and you
knew it was false at the start, yeah, go back and fix it, but
if I accuse you of something and some of the facts don't pan
out, well, I don't have to go back and fix that at this point.
That's not how that works. That's not how this works.
So, anyways, they're screaming about this, and they say indeed
plaintiff bends over backwards to justify your
Only highlighting your true motivation, using a public forum
to falsely class Destiny as a predator. Uh Destiny, your actions
have kind of put you in that light. I mean, the Listen, I'm not
saying this. This this Listen, every every problem Destiny has
with coverage of his case, this guy has his face on the screen,
he is in fact a lawyer, he is using his legal credentials, and
he also takes Destiny's side on some stuff, okay? There's There's
no way Destiny could get asked out about this, right?
No way. The idea that you you've done that you know, you have
a horrible track record with women.
I think a lot of people think you're already an awful person
when it comes to
I've got the clip. Someone sent me the clip. I just don't know
I haven't gotten a chance to watch it. So, apparently it was
from that that bigger stream. Presumably this girl didn't know
that that was happening that that was happen that came on the
court, right? Like she didn't know that this he was using the
pictures in that way, right? >> No, of course she did.
What do you mean? Yeah, she was sending him pictures to send
to me. What do you mean? He was asked He was the go-between.
Yeah, what do you mean? I Like that's the argument they made?
So, if he said this on a
then I assume that's going to get clipped and put
Right? Like if he said this on a stream, that's literally
agreeing with the argument they made.
That seems like a pretty big deal, right? The argument Pixie
made was that yes, saying he transferred these materials to somebody
else. Who's they?
Presumably this girl didn't know that that was happening that
that was happen that came on the court, right? Like she didn't
know that this he was using the pictures in that way, right?
>> course she did. What do you mean? Yeah, she was sending
him pictures to send to me. What do you mean? He was asked He
was the go-between. Yeah, what do you
Yeah, so he was the go-between to send the pictures to me. She
knew what was going on. She was getting pictures from pictures
and videos from Destiny. The guy was transferring them to her.
And that's what Pixie's team argued was, "Well, actually, there
was like he just functioned as a mediator." If if And that's
if you believe that she didn't have access to the account. She's
saying, "I I did all the things as if I had access to the account,
but I didn't actually have access to the account because
if she had access to the account, then she is liable for transmitting
child So, Destiny is now arguing that yeah, of course she had
full knowledge and she did, obviously.
Right? So, what Pixie's team argued is there's nothing wrong
with them saying that there was material traded between Bonnell
and a minor material transmitted between Bonnell and a minor
because it was done through a proxy, through a
That was the argument they made when they responded and Destiny
agrees that that is what happened.
So, I believe they're still disputing that and I I think The
funny thing about them disputing that is they want to get That's
why they filed for sanctions cuz they want to dispute that, right?
And the funny thing is is if he agrees with their argument and
the judge sees that he agrees with the argument, then I'm like,
"Oh, aren't you going to get like a judge to confirm that you
did exchange material with a
of what? Knowledge of what? Wait, Ally, what are you confused
about? He is saying that Rose absolutely knew that she was taking
pictures, nudes, and making videos especially ex- explicitly
for Destiny and only for Destiny.
And that she was receiving videos back from him. She had full
knowledge of what the videos she was recording were going to
be used for, i.e. sending them to Destiny, right? That is He
is agreeing with that. That is fully agreed to. I Assuming there's
not a significantly more context to this that takes it out of
that context entirely, but I don't think there is. That's why
I said, "I Listen, I hadn't seen the clip yet, so I haven't I
haven't come back out and said or or and watched and seen like
what the full context here is. Maybe there's something that makes
this make more sense.
Cuz that to me is insane to admit full knowledge that she was
making for whom? Presumably this girl didn't know that that was
happening that that was happen that came on the court, right?
Like she didn't know that this he was using the pictures in that
way, right? >> No, of course she did. What do you mean?
Yeah, she was sending him pictures to send to me. What do you
mean? He was She was sending him pictures to send to me. What
do you mean?
That's like what the the stuff was being produced for, to send
to Destiny.
She knew that she was making
either lewd or or nude pictures and to send to Destiny.
Equally troubling after refusing to withdraw the allegation and
file a corrected pleading during the safe harbor period,
they instead filed a retaliatory Rule 11 emotion against Destiny.
Um they didn't merely refuse to retract her false and hor- hol-
wholly, not horribly, not That's what Pixie sees women are all
hoes. Um wholly irrelevant allegation, she doubled down. It's
like, "Well, then Destiny should love that." That's all he does
is double down.
You join late and I start boomeranging out. That's what happens.
It's weird. Yeah. Now, the plaintiff improperly seeks sanctions
against Destiny for merely demanding the plaintiff withdraw or
corrected plead- Wait, remember, if you do
a Rule 11 and it's frivolous, that's a subject to Rule 11 itself.
But anyways, they advance and maintain the false thing here and
claiming it was false. Um and then they seek to punish Destiny
and his lawyers for seeking to enforce the law.
You're like, "You can't say that about me." Oh. Okay, I'm back.
Now, Rule 11 requires people and it's correct. You make reasonable
inquiries and advise the court of any changes. Now, what you
may have to do there is you could say, "Look, yeah, we would
would we would withdraw that and say, yes, she wasn't a minor,
but the idea that it was wholly without merit, I think there
was a lot evidence to show that. And we're going to get to the
deposition here and the deposition doesn't make a whole lot of
sense about what happened because if this is the argument of
what occurred, you're like, "I don't know if that's legit or
not." Like the story doesn't seem to make sense here. I You know,
there's a lot >> I'm interested to hear his commentary
on that cuz I I do agree
that this is probably the thing to me
like people are oh, he she had no idea or or Destiny had like
no idea what was going on there and it's like, "Well, to Destiny,
I think there's basically no
right? Like there's essentially no change for Destiny at all
in this regardless of whether or not that guy is involved from
his side of what he sees.
I just think it's weird that he used the language that they used
specifically that he was a go-between. fusion I would argue in
how this worked out. All right, sorry. Anyway, like the idea
that well, actually he had no idea. He was just totally catfished.
It's like, "Well, wait, but why would that matter?
I don't I literally don't understand how it matters in terms
of like his culpability, in terms of him like verifying her age,
in terms of him waiting, you know, three or four days,
a week before sending the video to this person who he thought
was an 18-year-old sex worker but was not, right? It like doesn't
really help in any way for any any of the stuff. I don't understand
what it could possibly help with. It's very funny. Now, they
claim that the you know, the allegations are only false.
So, what they say there's first no dispute, Destiny never transmitted
a video to miss so-and-so.
So, this is Rose talking at the beginning. She says, "I'm more
concerned about myself cuz my address, picture, my card, and
everything got posted online."
And what does she say? Destiny did that. And she says, "Destiny
put my name and address on Twitter."
That's not true. I Yeah, that's not true. She did put or he did
put some of her information online. He was definitely critical
to her getting
but I don't think he put her Well, wait. Wait, did he He didn't
take like a screenshot of Kiwi Farms or something? Wait, did
he Wait, hold on. He might have actually put it in YouTube video
Yeah, cuz he likes to free school Kiwi Farms. Did he do one of
those moves where he like actually reposted all of her [__]
Probably not her address. Okay. It's called doxxing, right? She's
like, "Yeah." Well, there we go. Once he's We're starting that
way. We're starting that way. And then she says Destiny put together
a group of guys in Discord and that there was like a Discord
that he put together wanted to find Rose, which was me.
And he did. He had a Discord chat of like a strike team OF INDIANS.
GO, SIR. WE SHALL find her for you, sir.
Um these people found out all kinds of
>> Destiny said I went to blank and I think maybe my name
and I looked into blank
>> That's a Dude, I I'm going to outsource all of my the
shot now. All right, this is awesome. I just sit here and I laugh
and I Dude, that is crazy That was I disavow that. That was [__]
up. It's a [__] up thing he just said, okay? You're
like, "Wow, that's great job, Destiny. It's great job."
Um from there it just keeps going though and it says, "When did
you first become aware who Destiny is?" Um probably like December.
Ben is Solo. Ben really liked watching his streams.
In December of 2021 that happened.
And they said, "So, he we would watch his streams together and
like his YouTube video together." And you're like, "Okay.
Well, huh."
So, what's going on here with all this? You're like, He's really
victim blaming and so too, bonus? Yeah, I know. He's Listen,
he's the what they call the the Kiwi Farms lawyer, okay? Yeah,
he is Yeah, he is is a victim blaming? Yeah, for sure. Is the
guy's name Solo?
And, you know, he being Solo, what did she say? Yes. Um Ben is
Solo and that's what he went by online Solo 11 like. And I that's
all I knew him from, so I'm assuming the Solo guy that you guys
are talking about would be him.
Now, here's the thing. So, Rose is claiming that Solo, who lived
in another country, was forcing and using her to help create
material for him, that she was he was basically forcing her to
do stuff, which doesn't make a whole lot of sense, but okay.
You know, and she was threatened with basically her the exposure
of her nudes to her family and other stuff to her family, which
is actually a very common tactic among groomers and other pieces
of [__]
it's a little weird here
um because now the story is
and as this story has gone on here, guys, now Rose is now claiming
that Solo was pretending to be her
and Destiny was gooning
to one of his fans. Yes. This is like Mandy K. Destiny got Mandied
in a very like in a very real way.
Like this is ridiculous.
You know, this like did Destiny Solo tell you why he was catfishing
Destiny?
>> Um I don't know if he just said specifically. I just
think it's because he liked his content, his streams, and stuff.
He's also Ben was So, I don't know if he would derive pleasure
from it or not. Well,
yeah. I mean, you know, they like there there are all the videos
of Destiny out there doing stuff and then all the people who
think that, you know, who Destiny is with and like I think Nick
Fuentes, they probably kicked it off. But really, this is like
Mandy level stuff here. Getting getting a catfished by one of
your getting catfished by one of your viewers and then gooning
to that guy.
Oh, man. Oh, man. That's
you know, they ask Rose, "Were you aware that he created Discord
account under the name of Rose of the Garden in which he communicated
with Destiny?" Yes. "Did he share with you any of the messages
or videos
of all this?" Sometimes, yeah. Oh, man.
Ew. "Did he ask for permission to make account where you wear
the accounts?"
And she said, "Are were you aware of Twitter, you know, videos
being sent back and forth?" Yes.
You know, now you said you had not responded to those just now
regarding whether you had ever seen those Discord messages. Didn't
Ben say you screenshotted these messages?
And sometimes, but not those. None of the Discord messages? Not
the ones you had me see.
What does that mean? There's more?
Um but I didn't see those, the other Discord messages. Like,
yeah. So, it's like, "Well, what did she see?" I don't know,
but And then in this message Steven messaged the person he believes
he's talking to is 18, right?
I'm not going to say that it's like 100% for sure a lie,
but I will say November of 2021 is when she met Ben. Is she telling
the truth there? That would be interesting to know, right? Because
obviously,
and we can go take a look at this, Bernard tracks the age of
the person when they join your Discord. So the age of the account
when they join your Discord. All right?
And it sure seems entirely possible
that she met Ben in November of 2021. Apparently Ben made this
account. Apparently she made this account in or somebody made
this account in May of
So like
a little bit a little bit of like, hey,
it's possible he made like a rose of the garden or roses please
account before he ever met Rose.
It's possible. Does it seem likely?
Or do we think it's more likely that she made her own account
on Discord before she'd ever met this guy? Now there are other
possibilities, but to me it's like this story already seems totally
absurd to me
when the core piece that she didn't meet him until 2021.
The account is created before Destiny's ever talking so before
Rose and Ben ever
I should have covered this stuff before. Look, we're already
finding things. I don't know if anybody noticed this.
Isn't that I feel like that account that casts judgment on the
or doubt on the story, right? And all this. Hold on. Let me see
let's see when the solo account was made. What would would we
go against this if if the other account was made at the same
time? If we both get like May 21st, 2021 this guy made like both
accounts at the same time. I could see that being like weird.
So he made his account. I do think this is him. I'm pretty sure.
Cuz they were both joining at the same time here as well.
But this account is made June 1st, 2022.
So that would be you know, maybe it was his Discord account the
whole time and he made a second Discord account after the fact.
Possibly?
He's not 100% sure. He is not 100% sure she's 18. He's not 100%
sure she's here like, what's going on? What's going on here,
buddy?
And then once it got worse he said he family and he would come
and kidnap me and use me as his slave.
And it's very convenient all this manufacturing is seeming to
work out in Destiny's favor. You're like, oh, huh. How does that
work? How does that work? How does that work? I just it doesn't.
It just doesn't. And the idea that those threats are serious,
nobody would. Uh Lucy's bigger question, would a judge or a jury
believe Rose? I don't know. I mean, I can tell you it seems sketchy
as [__]
Seems sketchy as [__] but also this is not germane
to the point of whether or not he violated Cardi. Now if this
all comes in, oh my god, it's going to be rough for him. You
know, could Rose be trying to minimize her involvement? Sure.
Could she be telling the truth? Also possible.
But once again, it's a very convenient timing for all this truth
to come out. Very convenient timing. Especially if Destiny's
already said, I talked to her. I've dealt with her. It's like,
then how do you know? You know, like
make that make sense. And it doesn't really make sense. It's
like when you lie to your doctor because the truth is embarrassing.
Except in this case the truth is multiple instances of transmitting
and and monetizing stuff.
And you can be held liable for this as an as if you did this
as a minor, you were like selling child You can be held liable
for that. There'd be a statute of limitations, but she could
be incentivized to lie here. So like it's way more than just
embarrassing. It is like, no no no no no. She would be if if
she had and I I don't know that she had. This could be the way
it was, right? But if she had
it would
Do you have old clips of him doing that? No, it's in the logs.
Watch it back. When he talks to Pixie he says, I talked to this
person on the phone multiple
Um the solo person also says they talked together on Discord
multiple times.
Even if you are coerced as a minor in her state you could still
be charged. I remember but for the people that haven't seen it,
oh well. I'm not I'm not building a segment out like that right
now. Sean knows that she does here just don't make sense that
she doesn't remember having calls with Destiny, but she remembers
the rest of the situation.
And that you know, if she doesn't do what her boyfriend says
he's going to you know, kill her make her his slave. You know,
she doesn't remember having to go talk to this weird middle-aged
dude about gooning. I I don't I don't buy it. I don't buy it.
But she tries to say that. Um did you ever tell Ben you'd be
willing to speak to Destiny? Um and why would he say that? Um
and she's like, well, I don't know. And you know, she says, you
know, are you saying you never spoke with Destiny? I don't remember
calling him.
But no, I never messaged him. Um they say, did you speak with
him with him on Discord? I don't remember if I ever called him.
And then he they say, would you be surprised if he produced documents
in this case that he did speak with you? And she's like, yeah.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Hold on. Is that referencing like something that might be there?
They surely they would have brought this up if it's referencing
something that could have been there,
Like surely. AH, THAT'S THAT'S WEIRD.
And that weird guys, who's believable right now? Who is believable
right now?
I don't know. You you can make try your own conclusions there,
guys. And you say, does any of this they're showing your exhibits.
Does this trigger your memory when you spoke to them on the phone?
You know, they're trying to get this in to have her explain what
And um would you be surprised if you heard that he had produced
documents saying he spoke with you for hours on a call? She's
saying, yes, I would be surprised. So you have no record on that?
She's like, no.
Remember Destiny said, I've talked to her. I've talked to her
at length. Remember this is a >> What are you giving me
screenshots of? You're looking at the >> You know, we were
on all these Skype calls. Oh, that's not what this says. Sean's
wrong on this. This is not what it's saying here. This is a recording
of a Skype call.
That's what this is, right? It's a recording of a Skype call.
It's not that Destiny was on the Skype call. Sean's wrong on
that.
But this is him talking to Pixie about
Uh there shouldn't be Pixie says, is there more stuff that's
going to leak about and he goes, no, there shouldn't be no. I'm
sorry, there's literally zero excuse. I'd had phone combos and
stuff with this person. They were fairly close to me. It's worthless
to say at this point, but I'm super sorry. There's literally
no excuse. I won't say or confirm anything about them. If there's
any particular action or thing I can do just let me know. Wow.
The mask was solidly in place back here. It's not a
This is not a good place to be right now. Someday we will do
a research stream. Uh we've made all these arguments already
and produced the evidence on stream and shown it and like basically
if you don't know it you can go watch the old videos on it or
anything. All these arguments have been made on the stream before.
>> So is he lying? Is she lying? Are they both lying? What
is the truth? >> Uh Sheamus says they don't have the phone
they don't necessarily have like phone calls, but Destiny's talked
about, oh I talked to her a bunch.
And she's like, I don't remember doing that. It's like, well,
then who the [__] telling the truth?
Seems a little self-serving here and it seems like it talks to
Destiny quite a bit, doesn't it? I mean, I don't I mean, it doesn't
help Destiny with like any of the actual core problems with this,
right? Like the core problems with this are he retained the videos
sent to him for a long period of time. That's one of the core
problems. He
was with somebody who he didn't verify the age of who was right
on the line. He thought they were 18. The the person well, it
technically they were older it's a guy like in his telling, right?
In in the telling we have from the documents from the deposition.
we have somebody who appeared to be 18 or said they were 18.
Destiny barely tried to verify anything. And some like basically
it also blows out the entire idea of implicit consent because
obviously the idea of implicit consent is driven from the idea
that he could trust her. That's why I I would probably if I had
to bet say this is a lie.
He is trying to imply, I would never ever ever ever send this
to somebody I didn't know. He knows how bad it is to send it
to somebody he doesn't know at all, right? No, I would I would
even lean into this being a lie and Leilani lost. That like he
knows how bad it is. It's all irrelevant to the case, right?
No, it's not necessarily irrelevant to the case. It's not necessarily
irrelevant to the case because
he basically if Rose was sending stuff, I do believe it has to
be deleted and you would get a negative inference. Right? If
it was child he can't present it to the court.
It's like radioactive you can't present it. And I think Pixie's
side would get a negative inference and they'd say you have to
you have interpret this negatively for the for Destiny. And I
believe the negative interpretation would be that it's possibly
a video of Pixie. Although the deposition I'm sure that that
would be a difficult argument to make to be honest with you.
But if if you know, they were sending videos after it man, depending
on the timeline there could be a case where a video that was
recorded before she was 18 was sent to him after the date of
Cardi and somehow could be inferred to be like Pixie or something.
You know what I'm saying? I wouldn't say it's like irrelevant
to the case. There could be something here where one of the videos
sent could be argued that it could be the video Pixie like being
sent back to Rose or something retransmitted in some way like
I don't know. Maybe not in that case. Maybe that is Rose's transmission.
I'm totally sure.
It would just depend.
I think it could be relevant. It also speaks to the idea that
he's arguing for for the other charges for the state torts. Those
are like malicious or you could build up some sort of like pattern
of reckless disregard for this person's
And so no, it wouldn't be persistent link. Persistent link would
apply to everything before this. That's not a part of this argument.
Yeah, the inferred consent argument goes away and so because
he obviously didn't validate who this was or verify who it was
at all, right? Yeah, so that that goes away for these state torts
to make some kind sort of case on those.
Although if the Cardi stuff gets tossed then they have to go
to a different court and I don't know if they're going to do
that. >> Now they're saying that here's a message that
she sent to Destiny saying, my boyfriend just broke up with me.
And then you say he told me he loved me and then blocked me on
everything.
And they're saying it's accurate that would have been the day
you and Solo split up. Yes. And your testimony is you didn't
send this message Destiny. I did
That's some Mandy to your catfishing chat. Wow. Woah,
Yeah, this is him talking to William. >> doesn't support
that, but Destiny has stated he's talked to her before.
And he's talked to her for hours.
God, we're we're doing >> So, is this even correct either
is Destiny lying already here? accidentally. You know, a bunch
of the story doesn't add up right now.
Um this is very funny. This is why you basically can't This guy
knows. This chat Mandy guy in that YouTube chat
Destiny originally acted like him and Rose were super super close.
And then the second it became like, oh wait, she was under Never
mind. I I didn't even know her. I never talked to them once.
It's like It's funny how it just flips on a dime.
They reached an impasse. I'm sure Destiny at this point is like,
you know, I'm not giving you a dime. And, you know, from his
position if he thinks he's in the right, I know, great. Yeah,
you're not going to. Um I'm sure Pixie said give me $50 million
and I'm sure Destiny said hell no. So, yes, shocker chat, they
could not reach an agreement. They could I don't think so. I
mean, I don't know what Pixie would have asked for here. But
it's like on the record and the sad thing is is with I don't
know how they got this lie through when Desi literally said on
his own stream what the actual demand was before they broke off
talks before the lawsuit was filed. It went, hey, 15 million.
And he didn't go, you sue me. They went, no, that's absurd. Um
if you if you They counter offered and they said, if you take
down the Substack and apologize, you can keep the the money from
the GoFundMe.
And so that then there was Pixie another offer for Pixie's side
which was just make us an offer north of 150 grand and we can
like negotiate from there.
Right? So, that was the last offer was 150 grand above 150 grand
was where they Or maybe even above 100 grand.
And honestly,
looking back, that would have been a great deal for him, right?
But he said he always does the 15 million thing cuz it makes
him sound like a bigger victim which is just sad. >> not
reach any sort of mediated settlement. And you might say, well,
wait, why did this happen then if they were probably never going
to be able to
Well, remember courts like cases to resolve. It's less they have
to do. So, they encourage the parties to settle because usually
where there's a will, there's a way and there's usually some
middle ground.
Sometimes you get the cases and there is no middle ground. Well,
you have to find that out in mediation. And the mediator still
gets paid. Well, yes, the mediator gets paid no matter what.
And there are many federal district courts where that's mandatory.
Mediation is mandatory. I think you're right, 150k. I have the
video somewhere. >> where you have to try it. Means remember
they want you to settle these things out instead of making them
deal with it.
So, yes, they couldn't reach an agreement. You're like, shocker.
It's like, yeah, well.
I I I'm shocked as much as you are, chat. And yes, it's like
Nick and Aaron. Um at this point, you know, Nick's like, I'm
not settling ever. Okay, well, then yeah, having settlements
are goofy.
But the court can order them and enforce
Okay, somebody sent me this. >> more aggressive. We had
another call and then her lawyer was like, uh something along
the lines like, okay, wait, wait, wait. What about like just
make me like make me an offer over 150k. I'm like, this is What
the My What is this right now? This is so stupid. And so
So, that's again, I just got I get annoyed with people like 15
million and it's like that's that's where the negotiations ended
was north of 150k.
There are some issues about Pixie missing a deposition.
But the bigger one is her lawsuit is is the bigger argument and
you accuse me of being a is a massive problem. But yes, that's
>> the That is a second thing like what's the sanction,
but the one of like you accused our guy being a
and accused them of, you know,
you know,
crimes to a child.
You have that here. It's not part of the complaint. It's in your
filings now.
It's not relevant to the case.
We want to sanction for that. That's like the actual big thing.
That's the big thing here. But yes, not showing up for deposition,
guys. >> That That could be so that
You could argue it's not relevant. I don't think it's totally
relevant to the Cardi stuff.
But in terms of, hey, this person and even the catfish thing
that that does lend credence to the argument that you took no
efforts. Like when they're saying, I think he did this intentionally.
He took no efforts and he's sharing this video. That's that's
crazy, right?
I think there's some argument there for why it's relevant. It
just might not have been relevant in the specific back and forth
that they did it in cuz it could have been I can't remember if
it was in the motion dismiss or where the
I can't remember where that was.
is a big deal. Don't ever do that. Show up for your court dates.
Show up for hearings. If you can't make it, tell somebody. But
also don't ask and figure it out like the night before you can't
make it. They pointed out that since the beginning the court
lacks subject matter jurisdiction. That's because they're arguing
this happened outside the scope of Cardi's enactment.
And when it went uh when it went operative, when Cardi went into
effect, they're arguing this happened before that day and because
it happened before that day,
it's over. And that's true if that's the case, it's never able
to happen
at the federal level. And they say it is now the end of January
and discovery is closed. Yep.
Um the plaintiff's opportunity to establish subject matter jurisdiction
has come and gone and they're they're basically saying, Judge,
we think they haven't been able to do it. And they're saying
since filing the complaint, plaintiff has failed to establish
any evidence to demonstrate Destiny ever transmit This is This
is the part where it's like, um you're just lying.
Like you're actually just lying. I I realize Destiny in his mind
is totally discredited Abby, but she's not really She's not been
discredited in any way BEFORE THE COURT. OH, WAIT. THAT'S That's
the other thing I saw was I think I think Pixie's lawyers actually
do fire back in one good way here. And they basically point out
that Destiny made no attempt to question Abby
>> into the video to any in the one she recorded with him
in September 2020 to anyone after October 1st, 2022,
the date the relevant statute went into effect. And that is the
critical date, chat. Um we talked about it before, you have to
get past that line,
otherwise Cardi is not available to you.
If this happened to be September 30th,
2022,
it would not be available to her. If it was October 2nd of 2022,
it would be available to her. Your beautiful noises Pixie's lawyers
are terrible. Well, I said that. I'm not been thrilled with them.
They've not been doing a very good job.
To be Okay. Jeff and Posey In defense of Pixie's lawyers,
I'm not sure that they're getting paid. I'm not sure I'm not
sure how much they could possibly be getting paid at this
You know what I'm saying? Like I'm sure they are getting paid
something, but I'm also sure they're like cutting deals and and
trying to be like kind about this like in a lot of ways, this
litigation has been a lot of motions, a lot of stuff happening
and Pixie did not raise that much money.
Certainly not enough to cover this lawsuit. I doubt they're working
for free cuz I don't think Why are they saying Desi hasn't been
deposed? We have proof he was here.
Um I didn't think he was, but hey, 050, are you talking about
when he went to Lauren DeLuguna's deposition? says So, it assumes
all the facts are correct and rules to the facts of law. Yeah,
well, you're basically saying, Your Honor, Yeah, okay. all these
facts are correct.
Make a ruling who's right. You're linking a Jeffrey Epstein Epstein
deposition. I got it. Funny. Ha ha.
>> Because we're not We don't need you to find any facts.
We just want you to find apply the facts to the law and tell
us who wins.
Now, the thing is, if the other side says, Your Honor, there
are issues in, you know, there are, you know, material issues
in dispute. There are facts in dispute. The court then has to
say, well, if you guys disagree,
you got
Is Destiny at? Destiny has said that uh it cost him What did
he say? Like 100k a month or something? I thought he said like
100k a month
or something like that. I Now I I'm sure it slowed down now cuz
they're basically waiting for They've been just like kind of
waiting on the judges to rule on I'm sure it slowed down at this
point. They've not really been
They've not been posting a lot of motions and stuff, so I'm sure
it slowed
You got to go to trial.
Because I can't make that decision if if not everybody agrees.
If there is a if one party thinks there is a dispute,
a material fact, well, then we have to keep moving.
We can't do this. So, even though Destiny's saying it, that doesn't
mean he's going to get it. And obviously,
I'll spoil alert, Pixie never agreed to this. So, we're not we're
not there. There's opposition for all this. As this goes on though,
they say at first Destiny attempted or or Pixie attempted to
argue that Destiny transmitted the to Rose.
Then her amended complaint, they backtracked and alleged they
sent the video to Rose sometime in 2022.
I don't think it's actually worded that way, but once again,
you have a little bit of luxury and leeway with how you want
to characterize stuff.
Um the undisputed evidence obtained during discovery establishes
the transmission to Rose occurred in April 2022. And if that's
when that occurred,
Cardi is over. It's out and
if it is the case, then it's done. I still don't think that's
true because of the Abby thing, but oh, wait. No, no, no, I still
don't think this is true because of the Abby thing. Not that
I even know like I I have like some reason
believe that this is true.
Given that like the weird like peering into the future [__]
But I I don't know how to say for sure. Um they also claim though
that Destiny had sent it to someone else who goes by the name
Abby MC.
But neither Abby nor her allegates ever materialized. Well, there
were. Um despite the count the representations of Abby they refused
to accept a subpoena on her behalf. They don't have
Um they delayed providing contact information
and they finally provided an address of service it was a fake
address. Ultimately Destiny served Abby with a subpoena, but
she failed to produce any documents to support of the claims
of her declaration. Okay, but she could still make her claims.
Remember, you know, doing that is enough. You know, like I saw
this this happened. Do you have any documents to support that?
Well, you're you're your testimony is
The testimony is evidence and there were documents. Like what
happened and I think she even said, and maybe she didn't provide
this to Destiny, maybe she should have, but I thought she said
she had her side of the DMs saved. So, I feel like at some point
discovery that should be provided or provided to both sides,
I don't know. And yes, Lou, just saying there's a dispute doesn't
make itself a dispute, correct. But generally speaking if you
can show there's a dispute
the court's going to say, all right, well, I'm not touching this.
And they say, and after the preliminary injunction hearing, Pixie
admitted under oath she possessed no evidence that Destiny transmitted
the video to anyone after the effective date. And this is where
they cite from the court and this is the court asking Pixie
have you seen any transmission yourself or record of a transmission
as opposed to what somebody told you that Destiny sent. Have
you seen anything yourself?
And she says, no. Now, they move on from here and they say, nearly
after a year of litigation,
she has still failed to produce any evidence of it. Then they
say, no such evidence exist.
So, not only did she fail to do it, but she failed because there
is no evidence. Um in September Destiny filed a motion to dismiss
for subject matter jurisdiction under rule 12 B1. And guys, remember
we talked about this. You can do 12 B1, 12 B2, all the way up
to 12 B7. And those are motions to dismiss for procedural issues.
But is I mean, I I don't know. I'm I'm letting catching up from
Shawn. I'm letting Shawn catch me up on everything cuz I haven't
been following this stuff very closely. I see like bits and pieces,
but I don't ever like go through and do comprehensive reviews.
But Shawn >> Well, yeah, because if she learned about it
after the fact, then like the evidence itself would speak for
it. But yes, the preliminary injunction, like that's that's what
that's meant for is like, do you have any personal knowledge
of him directly doing it? Like, can you verify where this happened?
And she says, no, I can't. That stuff goes on. They point out
that in light of the deadline to submit in light of the summary
judgment filing deadline. Remember, the courts will submit all
kinds of court all kinds of deadlines. Of dispositive motions,
motions to summary judgment motions, motions in limine. You know,
when is discovery closed? How is discovery governed? Um they
renewed their arguments in the 12 B1 motion and you should. You
renew it. There's no There's nothing wrong with doing that. Um
they submit motions for summary judgment with supporting documents
and once again, you have evidence now. You introduce along with
these summary judgment motions. Because the rule 12 B1 motion,
guys, that 12 B1 motion is literally just the motion by itself.
The four corners of the document. When they make arguments, summary
judgment rule 56, it's the four corners of that document plus
whatever garbage you offer.
And they go on to say that to demonstrate beyond, you know, they
Does Shawn normally have reasonable coverage? Shawn is not going
to view some of the facts for Destiny positively in his favor.
Like he doesn't like Destiny, thinks he's a weird disgusting
pervert, correctly by the way, but I will say on procedure on
matters of procedure he does know. He's a civil litigator. He
He's I believe litigated
that in federal civil court.
And then
so I like most of his stuff on legal procedure I I trust him
on.
We'll see. We'll see how it goes. It's been pretty good so far.
I think he got like one or two things wrong factually, but they
they're not super substantial. They do this to demonstrate beyond
any dispute he never transmitted the video to Rose, Abby or anyone
else after Cardi window effect on October 1st, 2022.
And because of that they lack subject matter jurisdiction and
that's true. This is the date that matters. Once again,
10/1 of '22.
So, I think
I we'll see if in the statement of facts basically Abby seems
to have knowledge of this video of Pixie
after October 2022 and they didn't meet until I think March 2023.
So, Abby seems to know about this know about this video, say
she was sent this video to other people
and they met each other after October 1st, 2022.
So, to me that's like that's what you have to explain and I don't
know how a jury handles that. I I would wonder if Shawn would
have some idea cuz like that's the argument it seems like pretty
obvious what the argument would be. And it's civil court, so
it's just balance of probability, right? What lawyer will you
watch after the Destiny conviction? He won't be convicted at
most he'll be held liable. I don't know if he'll I mean, as it
is I don't think
I don't know if he'll be convicted. I I can't see it particularly.
He would have to be a particularly disgusting person to lose
this case, I think. It's just It's going to come down to the
Abby stuff and I'm not totally sure how that'll go.
I actually don't even know I wonder if Abby would actually testify
here. Unless she was shown it from Darius or something before
she met Destiny. Yeah, but then why wouldn't that have just been
said? That's the thing is like I think Abby was in Destiny's
apartment. His computer's like unlocked and he says he wasn't
there or some [__] like that. And he he goes, well,
she found out about the video because she looked at my computer.
And it's like, well, cuz I think she says, oh, crazy leaks here
cuz she's taking a picture of Destiny's computer screen, right?
It's like, well, if she found out about it that way or through
Darius why wouldn't we just see DMs to that effect from Darius?
Why wouldn't Darius have just put reproduced those and like saved
Destiny right from the beginning?
I don't know.
Seems pretty crazy. Now, they're claiming and this I don't think
it's disputed the video was created in 2020.
And we're not going to go back through No, you're wrong, Ghost
Cheese. She So, she wasn't deposed.
But why do they have to depose her when they have a a sworn statement
or a What is it? Not a sworn statement, a
it's like under penalty of perjury she alleges this is true.
Do you have to depose for that?
Is is the statement itself not enough? Am I crazy on that? Maybe
the affidavit.
So, you have to be deposed. It's an affidavit is not enough?
Cuz I would I would wonder why an affidavit is not enough.
Cuz it's a guarantee you'll the history of all this because
um you know, they developed a friendship and they began discussing
their sex lives. Destiny transmitting never gave said the video
to Abby. >> So, remember Destiny's kind of done that, you
know, home brewed data table he put together. So, is that really
credible? I don't know. I would argue it's not and I don't think
a court's going to like the fact that the only person who can
vouch for the authenticity of the data
is Destiny himself
and there's no way to independently verify any of it. Like that's
a big big problem here. Um Okay, well, I feel less insane. >> to
be an FSU fan. That's cool. Absolutely not. I'm trying to get
to the next topic. >> an implied consent thing. I think
that's a little
I understand that there's a little bit of an issue there with
that, but I think at the end of the day a reasonable jury could
find
there was an implied consent.
So, if Destiny clears all those hurdles, yes, could he make the
implied consent argument at trial? I don't know if we're even
going to get The implied consent argument doesn't matter with
regards to
Um it it could matter with the other ones, the state torts, but
they'll have to go to a new court for the state. They have to
go to But let's say it goes to trial. Could Destiny make the
argument of implied consent? Well, 100%. Oh, I see. Would a jury
agree with him on that? I don't know. That's not a It's not a
good look if you're having to make that argument.
Especially if you don't have explicit consent. Yes, it still
is defense and the judge seems to acknowledge that during his
hearing. Yeah, no, it still is defense, but even let's say there
was no implied consent is my point.
Let's say this is 100% Destiny just did whatever the [__]
he wanted.
This conduct would be outside of it even if it is wrong and nasty
and mean
it's just not covered
is the point I was trying to get at.
But that's a very good question the way you kind of asked that.
Hmm. Could Destiny flee his civil civil charges? He's not facing
any criminal charges, guys. And I said this before. Is this If
this If this wasn't Destiny, you guys wouldn't be sitting here
saying like, you know, there should be charged for it. I think
the idea that we charge people for revenge is a little ridiculous.
Um I think there are, you know, statutes against harassment and
other things that are out there. I think operate well enough.
I don't think there needs to be more laws to criminalize people's
conduct like that in this No admissible transmission, no admissible
evidence of the transmitting of the video to Abby exist.
Um now, this is where you get to an issue, the false. I mean,
are they false? I don't know if they're false. Uncorroborated.
I mean, if we're talking about uncorroborated, I mean
I'll leave that alone. And the untested claims in Abby's declaration
are
by the evidence that actually exist. Pixie can't identify a material
issue of disputed fact
by relying on anything contained in Abby's declaration. Um and
yes, and this is the thing. You must point to more than some
evidence. You have to show
evidence that is significant.
You can't just say, and this is where they talk about the mere
existence of a scintilla of evidence in support of your position
is
And that's also like the the smallest little bit. Okay, well,
that's in doubt. That's not enough. You have to show there's
some material facts in dispute. It doesn't have to be all of
them, but it's got to be enough that if the jury heard it they'd
say they could say, yeah, we think you're right, Pixie. He's
wrong.
So, it's obviously a little more than that. Time is saying, aren't
most online services required to keep the records for 5 years?
Yeah, but I don't know if they're like but the records don't
mean like literally everything. That's what the NSA does. And
Edward says, I've noticed Destiny's lawyers are willing to go
full Russell Greer to try to win. No, they they have not they
might bend the facts
in their the most favorable way for themselves, but I haven't
seen anything to indicate Destiny's lawyers have done anything
unethical or illegal
at all. I've not seen any of that unethical or illegal conduct.
I agree with that. >> They're playing hard nose. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. You know You think Andy B's going to risk the
biscuit for
You think he's going to risk his whole practice for Destiny?
I don't think so,
I I I don't know. >> up on the flying jamming up pics like,
you know, it's a cornerback up on the line of scrimmage jamming
up a wide
It's business, man. Their job is to represent their client and
zealously represent him. So, they're going to go hard in the
paint. That's their job. I'd be more upset if they didn't.
But no, they're doing their thing. They're doing their thing
and that's nothing that uh you should be expecting. How Cardi
gets applied or what are the words in Cardi
For ask the files that Destiny had by a different names. And
we've gone through a lot of this issue here. They also say that
this establishes Destiny and put it on the Google Drive.
And if he did share those links, it was to somebody named Peach
and they don't depict Pixie. Which once again just shows you
Destiny does this [__] all the time. He's just wheeling
and dealing nudes. It's like this is more of a I guess philosophy
point of if you do this all the time, should you be really surprised
that you end up getting sued?
Maybe this is an indication of you probably shouldn't engage
in this conduct. But I'm a Scandinavian incel prude. So, what
do I know? But it's amazing if he didn't do all this
he wouldn't have been sued and he wouldn't have had to spend
probably north of you know, three quarters of a million dollars
at this point
defending himself. Like this would have been a lot smarter for
him. But just saying that's just something to think about, Chad.
Just something to think about there. They say the Three quarters
of a million. Do we think it's over that?
I don't know.
I I I'd say
if Pixie's only goal here was to make sure Destiny understood
how painful this was, she's probably been successful.
That was actually her only goal was to you know, That's what
she said originally. I just want to make sure this guy understands
that this is unacceptable and he never does it again. I do think
if if that was actually her only goal and she didn't need to
win money, then probably she's been successful. >> The
entirety of Destiny's relevant logs have been filed with the
court.
The video appears nowhere those logs and for good reason. Well,
according to him. Destiny never transmitted video of Abby at
any time. Pixie cannot
proffer admissible evidence to dispute that fact. You guys remember
proffer is just saying offer it and you know, be able to explain
any evidence there. Abby fails to support the claims in her declaration.
And they point out as part of a rule 26 disclosures and that's
where you can serve subpoenas on people.
Pixie identified Abby as a potential witness and submitted a
declaration.
They made it exceedingly difficult to test the statements contained
in the
And they say the attorneys for us and they go through all this
saying we couldn't find her. They wouldn't help us. Now, they're
arguing though they were prevented from testing the veracity
of her claims and they're saying that should warrant exclusion.
And this is true of the rules of civil procedure. You must without
awaiting a request provide to the parties the name if known the
address and telephone numbers of individuals likely to have discoverable
information. Yes. Um you must also supplement disclosures at
appropriate intervals. Yeah. I have a case right now where my
client just said, "Hey,
I have some more I found some pictures.
I was digging through one of my old phones and I found some pictures
of the thing we're dealing with." Destiny did the one thing
most law cows
usually [__] up. He didn't do it. He went out and
got good counsel. A lot of law cows get law cow lawyers.
You know, Destiny went out and got very good lawyers.
So, that actually helps him a lot.
Uh no matter what happens, Andrew Brettler is the biggest winner
in this case. Of course he is. The made all kinds of money on
it. Yes. The attorney always wins. It's The attorneys are like
the the the house in gambling. The house always wins. It's I
get it. What do you do? Now, does Abby have her original logs?
I don't sound like don't sound like it or don't sound like they
have a way of verifying it. I think people were saying for a
while Abby was like homeless and wandering around. So, does she
even have like a phone and access to all that crap? So, but ultimately
they're going to make the arguments here the same things we've
already talked about these before. Talked about it about >> he
going to talk about the end There's nothing in Google Drive to
show you this. And they're saying the court has declined to exercise
supplemental Is is Ghost She still here? Cuz I do think that's
an argument I see from Pixie's lawyer at some point is there's
no deposition from Destiny's side. And so, I think they're going
to argue that there was like they weren't really disputing that.
I don't know. I don't know if that How does that affect it? If
there's no deposition from if Destiny's side doesn't try to depose
um Abby, does that make a difference?
supplemental jurisdiction over the remaining of this. And this
is something courts can do. Generally speaking, if you have just
one federal claim and other state law claims the court generally
dismisses the case because it has no jurisdiction over them.
There are times where courts can
keep what's called supplemental jurisdiction
over those state law claims. They can do it. Now, the thing is
and this this is the case though in Gibbs if the federal claims
are dismissed before trial, the state claims should be as well.
Um and notice the district courts may
decline, meaning it's discretionary
if they've dismissed all claims over which it has original jurisdiction.
Which is Cardi. So, they can get rid of it. They don't have to
keep it. And honestly, the court's going to be like, "I don't
want to deal with this." So, if Destiny wins this, it's going
to get kicked out of federal court. I don't
the judge being motivated or wanting to keep this. I mean, certainly
he would And and think about if you were the judge, would you
want to keep this? No.
You're going to pull that grenade You're going to pull the pin
on that grenade and throw that in some other like you go throw
that at the state court. Throw that in the state court and let
them deal with it there. The law cow lawyers, is that what I'm
going to call the new law firm down there? That would be
Yeah, that's not what I'm going to do.
They move on here and they say ultimately Destiny should get
a motion If Destiny didn't get the judge to issue a motion to
compel, then the judge could still let her testify. I see.
I don't know if there's been a motion to compel yet. We could
I'll check it one second. motion for summary judgment. You're
like All right. All right. Yeah. Yeah. Motion for summary judgment.
Like I think it's well put together. I think you know, they go
through it and they
what they want to do. What they want to do here. Let me see.
Do I have
From here, obviously
um and I forgot before we get too far
we need to cuz people asked me what are
Yeah, this notice of 90 days expiring
thing here. People have asked me what this is about cuz there's
a couple times this pops up.
And where this pops up, you guys just so you understand
this is something you file.
Both sides have filed these.
And it's nothing super special, but you just come into the you
come into court. You come into you file a notice of 90 days expiring.
And they submit a notice per suing to local rule and the local
rules say you have to do this.
Um you submit the following notice that 90 days have elapsed
since the parties fully briefed a motion.
Now, what does that mean parties fully briefed? Remember, you
have the party makes a motion, the movant.
There's a response. They reply back. They make you know, they
they respond.
And then you get the reply to that
So, remember it's a very limited dance. It should be three motions
or three >> There has been no motion to compel like a deposition.
There is no Yeah, there's been no motion >> relating to
a motion topic.
There's the motion
the response
and then the reply.
And then from there the judge should make a ruling. And they're
just saying, "Your honor, it's been 90 days."
They point out we did this one in December 4th.
There was a supplement December 8th. The defendants replied on
December 17th.
And that this is important though. Remember, they're going to
paint the facts in the most favorable light to Destiny's document
production is deficient and reflects indicia of alteration and
improper preservation.
Once again, whether or not it's true how he did these things
people are going to look at it and say it looks all cat
you know, or fabricobbled. It's going to look It looks like chicken
and stucco.
So, yeah, that that is a problem for Destiny. And they say we've
had to do further discovery including a motion to compel a potential
spoliation relief. Which I don't think you're going to get. It's
just he doesn't have any records and tried to put together a
record. I never said Destiny was respons- or responsible or reasonable.
I said his lawyers are. That's all. I mean, the idea that he's
claiming he deleted stuff, sure. That may get you a little bit,
but I don't think that's going to be enough. Pixie's been able
to pursue such relief today due to defendant's lack of cooperation
and conduct has impeded discovery efforts. And this goes back
to Um, and Lou, I don't know if you've been here the whole time,
but the earlier parts of this where they were complaining that
they were worried Destiny was destroying evidence and spoilating
evidence.
But at that point they hadn't asked for any requests for production.
They hadn't requested any documents or electronically stored
information. They just ran to the judge and said, "OH MY GOD,
JUDGE, HE'S deleting everything." They never asked for anything.
So, they [__] around for like a month or two not
asking for anything when they thought it was happening. The moment
you're in a case and you are getting ready to serve a request
for production and discovery and you learn that the other side's
doing it, um, you have to go. Get that discovery request out.
Like, the idea you didn't know Destiny's ex-wife lived in Sweden
and you're going to have to basically hunker down because she
could easily say like, "Yeah, I'll make myself available." She
could fly here to America and you could serve her with a a subpoena
and like you can that can happen. That could have been worked
out, but it sounds like she's not doing that. It sounds like
she's like, "Nope, I'm hanging out with my millionaire husband
right now, living the high
So, you're going to have to go find her.
This should have been like started They should have been working
on this from the start. Like, from the jump.
We're working on getting our You know, you follow your complaint,
you start working on figuring out subpoenas and how you're going
to have to go after this person. Because if you do that, you
say, "Your Honor, from like day one we knew this was going to
happen. We're going to have to go get her." You know, the court's
probably like, I can see if I was judge, I would 100% say, "You
guys are busting your nuts. It's only been This case is barely
a year old. Rock on."
But when they've been around a little bit, it's like, "Did you
not know Destiny was married?" Well, no, we knew that. I mean,
that's that's a problem for me. That's a problem for me. The
testimony of Destiny is very important. Yes, and if they haven't
been able to get him to sit down for a deposition, that's a big
problem, especially if that's, you know, there have been problems
on Destiny's end and from what I've been able to parse through
the record on, yes, there is. Luke is saying both teams in this
have been generally slow. Can't send doc requests until discovery
starts, but you can send a litigation hold. If they delete after
litigation hold, you can claim spoliation. Which I think is what
they say happened, right? Um, like he was notified like not to
delete documents. Although, I guess it could have happened in
in the middle as well.
He deleted documents after he was like when he knew he was going
to get sued, he deleted stuff, but before he was served with
anything, right? Anyway.
He made a big stink about Jane Doe not appearing for in-person
deposition.
Yeah, basically the thing that happened
apparently they got something set up with the court where Pixie
was supposed to come in and testify. Joan
I think they just Pixie like couldn't go because she was in class,
right? And basically when they were discussing
Pixie basically gave a window.
It seemed like kind of unfair, but somehow it got set up with
the court that Pixie was going to come in and get deposed and
then she didn't make it. She didn't go in, right?
I I don't know how it happened or how it was allowed to happen
that she would get like scheduled that way, to be honest with
you.
But I it seems like, you know, that's a big problem. And then
they said we're not going to go in until Pixie goes in. Like
Destiny's side went and said, "We're not going to go in until
Pixie goes in." And then there's just never been any movement
there cuz the judges haven't ruled on
or the judge hasn't ruled on So, I yeah, I just we're waiting
on some rulings to come down to say basically to resolve that.
But because of that gridlock, there's been no deposition of either
the primary people. Strange. Yeah, but remember, ultimately the
plaintiff's the one that has to move.
Um, when you're on defense, there's only so much you can do proactively.
They just noticed a deposition. They don't have to go to the
court for that. Oh, okay. Um, there's still times where you're
going to be in a reactive state. Um, I think in I think Destiny
should have been moving for a kill quicker, but I think, you
know, he probably could have won a 12b probably won a 12b6
Um, and then gone out and have done all that. I think Sean said
if they if they filed a 12b6 the second this got filed, it probably
just gets dismissed. Like, things get litigated out a little
bit and then it probably just gets dismissed. Didn't they initially
file the TRO? No, it was just a complaint.
There was no TRO right off the bat, which is a problem. There
was a I think there was an injunction. There was a PI or TRO
right off the bat, which was the protective order. Sorry, there's
a protective order right off the bat. They combined filed with
a protective order for Pixie's lawyer or for Pixie being Jane
Doe. Is what that guy was thinking of. Wouldn't make any sense
to the shooters to submit to this. You even And just like you
might say, "Well, what do you put in there? Do you admit that
you did this? Yes. Do you admit you did this after the date of
Cardi? Do you admit you caused intentional infliction of emotional
distress?" If they're dumb enough to answer yes, you take it.
But usually they're going to say, "No, we deny."
Um, they say Pixie is thought to schedule Destiny's deposition
beginning on September 17th, two weeks after the entry of the
order and commencement of discovery. Um, they point out it was
scheduled for November 6th, at which point Pixie would have had
sufficient time to seek appropriate relief, including spoliation
sanctions.
So, they said ultimately they point out here, where they going
to get to this? The disclosure of the video to could have 100%
won on a 12b6. I asked in his chat why he didn't file one and
he gave a BS answer with the tone of someone who's a partner
at Skadden. Well, I
I've seen him answer that question before and it's just like
I think basically
he figured it was pointless and he didn't want to I think it
was just a cheapness thing. I'm pretty sure it was just a cheapness
thing. Like, literally I'm thinking they said, "Well, there's
a low chance we win on this cuz they probably have like this
other information.
And I'm guessing they said like, "Do you want us to write up
a motion?" And he was looking at the costs. It was probably like,
"Nah, nah, nah."
I I I feel like that's the advice he got was, you know, it's
not not likely to succeed or because I think when the when the
case was first filed, I think they assumed there was just more
evidence there that was being held back that wasn't being held
back. It was.
Now, what do they make the argument Assuming even an argument
for the sake of argument, Destiny disclosed the video to Rose
prior to October 1st,
Pixie contends the manner of the that disclosure rendered inaccessible
after that date.
And if it's available for Rose to keep clicking or Solo to keep
clicking and watching and downloading,
then it's still active.
The plaintiff must depose Destiny to determine how the video
was transmitted,
when and where he deleted the video attachment from the Discord
chat thread, and Destiny's knowledge of Discord's well-documented
security vulnerabilities
relating to the exposure of user
Meaning, are you sure that nobody else got a hold of it?
Answers questions are directly relevant and may yield additional
evidence supporting her claims, which it's true. That can lead
to more discovery and more claims and more evidence on its own.
And without Destiny's deposition, they can't adequately redress
or rebut assertions on summary judgment. Remember, Destiny's
saying, "I did it right." Well, we haven't a chance to test you
either. And it's funny because they go on and beat this drum
about saying, "Well, Abby has not been tested.
Abby's untested.
Destiny is untested.
Destiny has not been deposed.
So, Destiny's in the same boat as Abby right now and it sounds
like Sean kind of agrees with the argument that if you if we've
had no depositions, how how are you even supposed to do discovery
if you can't depose the the primary person from the other side?
Like, that seems crazy.
And it does kind of seem crazy, doesn't it? Like, I I don't I
don't even understand. And once again, Lou, this kind of goes
back to your argument of they don't have to prove anything. You're
right. But when you start once again arguing, "Hey, judge, look
at this pile of dog [__] that I just lit on
you know, you're now forcing the court to look at your pile of
dog [__] and if you start then [__] around
in the
well, now you're already
By the way, I like I just heard about So, they're doing they're
challenging three categories of evidence and they want to exclude
it at trial and they say pursuant to the rules of federal federal
rules of evidence, 401, 403, doing any evidence that Destiny
transmitted the video to a minor,
they're arguing that's absent from the amended complaint, has
no bearing on any element of her claims, prejudice the jury,
and is subject to Destiny's motion for sanctions. Yes. I would
say I would say that probably
the decla-
I unfortunately think
this can't be dismissed unfortunately, right? Cuz he's arguing
that No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, we had an implied consent
argument. That implies I trusted you to and it does involve trust
because as he says, I believe he's actually argued this and I
hope they make this argument. But he's argued that when Pixie
said it was okay for him to for somebody to see it, it was Molina,
Destiny's wife, like somebody core who he trusted, right?
That's like the implication. That's the argument he's been making.
And so, wouldn't make sense to actually have implied consent
with somebody you like you literally just met a week ago? No.
No, there's like no universe where that makes any amount of sense
at all. Right? So, unfortunately, the fact that she's a minor
really does drive home just how stupid you were in sharing this
video, just how little work you did trying to validate her identity
or her
How trustworthy she was, right?
Declaration attached says that any testimony from >> I mean,
that's that's the argument they would make. I could still see
them going, "Yeah, but like her age specifically, you could say
that, you know, he knew this person for a week."
But and I could see that going either way. Um non-party witness
Abby
um and they say counsel representing Abby obstructed
and ultimately Destiny couldn't serve the subpoenas.
They're saying that's all hearsay because they couldn't challenge
it and therefore should be excluded.
And they're talking about Pixie's use of a pseudonym at trial.
While a while pseudonymity may be permitted in limited circumstances
during pretrial,
its continued use before a jury would unfairly prejudice Destiny
as it suggests without proving that death that Pixie is deserving
of some special status or protection as a victim. That
that a good argument? Why
why would that be a good argument? Like I Okay, here's how this
is going to go. Shawn is
I love Shawn, okay, but he's a he's fairly he's like a fairly
brain-broken libertarian type who's going to say this violates
the constitutional protection or constitutional right to face
your accuser and or so something like this, right?
I guarantee you he's going to regardless of what the law is cuz
clearly by based on the fact that she has a pseudonym
like why would this law exist if this was a good argument? Why
would you be allowed to even make this why would you be allowed
to even file and and get this protection this protective thing
if this argument worked? Well, it actually it's
it's um prejudices the jury. Then this wouldn't exist, right?
It couldn't exist.
Anyway, I think he's I think he's going I I think he's basically
going to argue against what the law is here, probably. is entirely
a very good argument to Um that is actually very fair. That's
a very good one to make.
It's prejudicial to give her any special
Make her use her name. I think so. At some point she's going
to have to spill
Running through the whole trial as Jane Doe is a little ridiculous
in my opinion. I agree.
At some point it's walk time, Pixie.
And I don't have a problem with them asking for that. I think
that's totally
Yeah, he >> point out, you know, we've gone through the
rules 401 and 403 before. I would just say if that is a good
argument, I don't understand why this thing even exists. And
it's all about whether or not evidence is admissible. And you
start out, what's evidence? And let's go through the rules as
we go here.
Oop, what's not Oop, that's wrong. It's a rule 401. So, what's
relevant evidence? It's if relevant has any tendency any tendency,
meaning a little bit or a big or small enough or significant
enough to make a fact more or less probable than it would be
without any consequential even a little fact being consequential.
So, you deal with that Well, how do you Okay, great. But now
we go to rule 403.
Even if it's relevant, can we exclude it? Yes. You can exclude
relevant evidence if the probative value is substantially outweighed
by the unfair prejudice to a party. It's confusing the Oh, I
could see him winning on this one though. That's That's where
if he's going to win on the getting rid of this this evidence,
like the fact that it's a minor, if he's going to win on this,
or sorry, if he's going to get it excluded, it would be on 403.
And it's that the probative value is outweighed by the how much
it prejudices the jury. Once you make him look like a to the
jury,
then that's absolutely like then the jury is going to be against
him no matter what, right? As soon as you make him look like
a to the jury, he's And so realistically, while this is good
for your arguments, it probably makes you win the case no matter
what somehow. Like it's it's sort of and I do think it could
be I think you you get a lot of the probative value from talking
about how she knew him for a week
he knew him for a week and this material was of a minor. Because
if you're a minor and suing someone from you, if there's a cause
of action, you use Jane Doe throughout.
Yeah. Sure. Yeah. issues? Oh, I I don't know if it's only pretrial
that she gets to use the Jane Doe stuff. I actually don't know.
could mislead the jury, there's undue delay, it wastes time,
or it needlessly presents cumulative evidence. Destiny keeps
on hitting these points and this is actually really good. You
go back through and say, "Judge, look, it's really prejudicial.
By the way, this is the [__] we put in our rule 11
There's nothing wrong with just keeping
you're not screaming at the judge about it, but it's just like
it's in there right at the end. It's It's very snappy and like
I like that. It comes back to it. You're just like, "Judge, by
the way, it's at Well, like I think the thing is is the way you'd
argue this to a regular person, Ghost Cheese, is
if he'd made any effort to validate this person's identity or
their age, this would never been a problem because he would have
found that he couldn't get any proof that this person was overage
that this person wasn't an adult, right?
So, it it invalidates a lot on in terms of how much he trusted
them or not not the Cardi stuff, but for the other state
Where it talks about intentionality and what level of culpability
he could have, how intentional it could be. If you're going to
keep sharing these videos with people who are who you have no
nothing about, right? But I think that probative value is presented
entirely just by the probative value that you get from that argument
is the same as saying he only knew them a week.
Right? I And again, when you go from like he only knew them a
week to and they were technically the videos were of a 17-year-old,
yeah, you are. It's just like it prejudices the jury. You can't
paint somebody's while they're prejudicing the jury, so unlucky
man. that thing you never did. By the way, and you just keep
that and you keep bringing it up. And it's like the sales person
or preacher thing. You always keep that word, the rule 11, the
rule 11, the rule 11. You're just keeping it fresh in his
So, they point out that um
they're arguing you would divert issue away from the primary
issues. And they point out the alleged transmission must be excluded.
The probative value is outweighed by the danger of unfair prejudice.
I don't think the jury would be confused and it's also misleading
the jury. I think you just say it's un it's unfairly prejudicial.
Unfairly prejud They don't want to say flat out this makes my
Your Honor, this makes my client appear
and that was going to make it really hard to win.
Your Honor, that We're not saying they're lying. We're just saying
the evidence makes my my client look like a and has nothing to
do whether or not my client is a has nothing to do with this
So, it's going to make them all hate
but that has nothing to do with the case, okay?
And if you think if you really think about it, you know, if you
if you needed to include in some case that a defendant was if
you if you just put their race somewhere in um in something that's
totally irrelevant and somehow you could like tell the race,
but then you put something in there about their race or the race
of like their significant other or something and it somehow like
gets racist to dislike them. You're in like a racist jurisdiction
that Right? It's like it is technically something that is not
relevant to the case. Well, not directly relevant. judicial.
You know, giving the video to minor doesn't matter. Even if it's
true, it has no bearing on the Cardi case.
In order it requires that you disclose an intimate image under
circumstances
giving rise to an expectation of
And I agree, right? That's a fair argument to make.
The purported age of the recipient is irrelevant and any such
evidence should be excluded. I think that's fair. You don't need
that. Now, you could argue that it's something to go towards
his credibility and honesty. Certainly, and I'm assuming that's
what you know, we'll get to here in a minute.
And they say they obstructed access to Abby and disregard a subpoena.
We've already been through that. That they want to be able to
prevent that because we haven't had a chance to do anything with
it. That Abby's exhibit is not authenticated. It's inadmissible.
>> can give consent to send it to minors. I doubt it. >> I
doubt it. >> arguments. Or if he did, when? Now, that's
actually a fair argument to
Well, the only thing Okay.
I wonder if Shawn knows the argument cuz I I don't know how well
you can construct arguments like this for a jury or how much
like physical evidence types you need, okay? I don't I don't
know how much I don't know how much you need that.
Like it seems pretty obvious and straightforward what the argument
is. Abby's aware of these these people of these videos. She met
him after the date of Cardi. She says she was sent the video.
Those three things put together, given that she proved that she
knew had knowledge of the video beforehand, she
that or she she it is proven or accepted that she didn't meet
Destiny until after Cardi came into effect,
um then that lends credence to the other claim that she was sent
the video.
Cuz how else would she have known about the video? When is the
big thing here? And that cuz again, the Abby is talking to friends
about the video she got sent of Pixie
in 2023, right? So, she she says in 2023 I was sent this video
and she knows something, right? At the most, the exhibits reflect
Abby's own characterization of what she believes she possessed.
Not evidence that Destiny actually transmitted the video. And
then ultimately, But again,
as much as that's true, I I do think that's an argument that
should be able
to be made in front of a jury. I think, but I don't know. Ghost
Cheese, what do you figure?
Does that go to Like do you think is that an argument you can
make? Like it feels like that's something that should go before
a jury that that's a material difference a material like disagreement
that should be before a jury. They um they say it should be excluded.
I don't think that's really going to be there, but I think the
kicking out the minor part unless they have an argument for it.
I could see that.
Should Pixie be allowed to use her uh pseudonym at trial? No.
I don't think she should. She should be forced to identify herself,
you know, because yes, being a victim is a perceived legitimacy
and sensitivity.
There was the order denying the protective order for public commentary.
That is entirely a very rational decision. I have no problem
with that one. Totally makes
Um the order I think they I think they could have gotten that
if they'd been more narrow. I think they're way too broad again
in how they asked for the order. I made that criticism back then
when they originally filed it, I think, that they were just way
too broad with Like you if you want an if you want
that is violating somebody's free speech, you need to narrowly
tailor it because every single time people are going to say first
amendment, most important amendment, I'm not violating their
first amendment rights unless it's like very very specific to
one type of
Yeah, but I think they mostly were like Destiny doesn't get to
talk about his case on stream. It's like, well, what about referencing
Pixie? Or yeah, like what if it's something along these lines,
right? Like being able to talk about his case, but not specifically
mentioning Pixie. Something there. I just thought it was way
too broad. Order denying the motion the order to show
is denying also the seal and motion for the order to show cause.
Order to show cause got denied, got
And rightfully so, have no problem with
Now, here's the thing, guys. You can address these at the time
of court and say, "Your honor, that's not relevant." It's easier
to get out in front of it though to do what you need to do at
that point. Hey, hold on. What was this again? This one was Pixie
goes, "Well, I have a motion
omnibus motion in the mean. >> to eliminate, too. You're
like, well, what? Is that what you say? >> motion to eliminate?
>> how you say that? Limine? >> for you. So. My god.
They submit this as their their own thing here, and they say
ultimately
we still have unresolved depositions.
They're also unresolved discovery issues. They haven't been able
to depose Molina yet, but it's like, you guys, that's your That's
their fault still. It's still their fault. Accordingly, they
reserve the right to supplement or amend these motions after
the court rules on them.
And a little tough. It's a little tough, but yeah, the court
I mean like can ask the court to hold this all in abeyance till
you figure it out. Now, they point out this is all about whether
Destiny disclosed the video without Pixie's
in the time frame of the law. Destiny's trial strategy I have
seeks to divert the jury from that question by introducing irrelevant,
prejudicial, and legally improper arguments.
Now, here's the thing, guys. You can address these at the time
of court and say, "Your honor, that's not relevant." It's easier
to get out in front of it though to do what you need to do at
that point. Barred from advancing implied
Which is foreclosed as a matter of law under the governing statute.
They say second Uh that's a bad argument for them to make. If
they're going to make that argument, that is that does apply
for Cardi.
That won't be for any of the other things. They say Destiny should
also be precluded from relying on self-generated spreadsheets.
I agree with that.
You know, there's no proof of them, and it would lead a mislead
a jury. Fourth, Destiny should be barred from presenting a so-called
catfishing defense
or related arguments that misstate the statutory definition of
disclosure
and bring in sub collateral issues.
So, what are we're not worried about the legal standard again.
Cuz it's the same thing as rule 401 and 403.
We're not going to We're not going into that because it's the
same thing Destiny's already brought up.
Now, they're saying implied consent should be excluded.
And they say that Pixie implied consent by participating in communities
where she shared images that she previously shared content with
Destiny or third parties suggested the video be recorded or consented
or participated to in creation of the video. I don't think Destiny's
going to argue that gives him the implied consent.
This is what they're going to argue gives implied consent, that
Pixie shared the video with a third party. That's the That's
the strongest argument for implied consent here. The rest of
these, I mean, if she was in a community where it's common, that
would also be a very strong point in Destiny's favor. You know,
the previously shared Create best community. Step one, create
best community. Step
benefit from best community. Fantastic. >> your content
with offender third parties. This one and kind of number two
and number five are kind of the same.
And I think that's actually very
And it says Cardi unequivocally requires explicit, not implied,
consent. It, you know, it defines consent as an affirmative,
conscious, and voluntary
made by the individual free from force,
misrepresentation, or coercion.
I think you can argue though your actions can imply consent.
I don't think
affirmative, conscious, and voluntary authorization made by the
individual free from fraud, misrepresentation,
or coercion. Where is the
Yeah, your actions could your actions need to it needs to be
like stated to Conscious. You need to be conscious of the the
fact that you're being asked of
Or asked this is being asked of you. I I do think it is basically
saying there needs to be an agreement, a direct agreement. It's
not I it's basically unequivocal. I don't know how he's arguing
You would be able to say that that's If Pixie makes that argument
in court, I think that's going to be a very tough sell to a judge.
That we can imply someone infer someone's mental state from their
actions. We do that all the time in the That's entirely reasonable.
Yeah, but is that for laws where it explicitly makes clear that
you can't just read an implication into something?
Like I I would think this is what this specific language in the
statute is meant to refer to.
Like am I crazy?
We got two legal people, the two just gamer and and ghost trees.
It seems like in Cardi when it says this that it needs to be
an affirmative conscious voluntary authorization made by the
individual. I I actually don't I don't even know cuz it seems
like in the law they're explicitly saying, "No, you can't just
rely on some understanding."
That's what it seems to be like. That's how it seems to be.
Well, the statute clarifies that consent does not constitute
consent to its distribution.
And that's why saying, "Oh, I agreed to have it recorded." That's
a weak argument. Or I participated in it. That's a weak argument.
Those ones won't go anywhere.
And it says prior disclosure of this picture to another person
doesn't constitute consent to further disclosure. Yeah, but I
think there's I don't think that that's going to be proper in
that. But actually, I do kind of want to see if that's exactly
what they're saying here because remember, these guys are going
back and forth back and forth and back and forth. You know, they're
going back and forth with each other, and it's getting a little
gay.